at the Grammys on Sunday a great crime
against humanity occurred with the
entire world watching Adele won the top
Grammy leaving Beyonce the greatest
human being who has ever graced our
planet out in the cold again why why God
why racism
never mind that Adele's 25 was the
top-selling album of the year while
Beyonce's lemonade showed up at number
four Adele had to apologize to Beyonce
for winning the album of the year and
then she split her Grammy in half and
said quote I can't possibly accept this
award the lemonade album was just so
monumental yes lemonade is
groundbreaking
Beethoven asked a work of heartbreaking
genius with which only heaven or heavens
angel could have seen fit to grace us
who else but Queen P could have given us
these immortal lines y'all haters corny
with that Illuminati mess paparazzi
catch my fly and my cocky fresh the
echoes of Shakespeare ring in every
romantic lyric so why would an artist of
color naturally assume that Adele's
victory at the Grammys represents a new
form of Jim Crow here's the New York
Times quote before the 59th annual
Grammy Awards on Sunday the music
industry murmured about what it might
mean for adults once again sweep the top
awards leaving Beyonce snubbed in the
major categories and with her third loss
for album of the year
having long faced accusations that the
Grammys overlooked young progressive
black artists the last woman to win
Album of the year was Lauryn Hill in
1999 The Recording Academy faced a
potential backlash for going all-in on a
white traditionalist choice like Adele
in the last five years especially albums
by Frank Ocean mr. Lamar and Beyonce
have been passed over for the top award
in favor of releases by white artists
Mumford & Sons Daft Punk Beck Taylor
Swift and Adele so now the Grammys are
just another repository of white racism
but it's not enough that everyone in the
music industry must pay tribute to
Beyonce it's not enough for the
top-selling artist on the planet to bow
before Beyonce as required under
international law no the Grammys must be
boycotted until they recognize that
incredibly rich incredibly beautiful
world-famous black people have to win
awards otherwise they are just Bull
Connor does anyone wonder why our
culture is falling apart why the social
fabric is fraying
we can't even listen to music or watch a
silly music awards show without being
hit with Colin Kaepernick lectures
on the legacies of slavery even while
the whole world falls prostrate before
the glories of juju celebrating ancient
fertility rituals re-enacted on stages
New Testament living tableaus yes
Hollywood clearly has a problem but it
isn't racism it's race-based stupidity
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show already so we will get to general
Flynn's elster in just one second and
there's a lot to talk about there
because it's a very confusing and
confused story there are a lot of angles
to it so we're going to analyze it from
every single available angle as we are
to do but first we have to say thank you
to our friends over at zip recruiter so
if you are an employer and you are
looking for a solid employee you could
scour the job boards you could put out
an ad in the classifieds or what you
could do is you could post your job to
200-plus job sites using zip recruiter
comm and that includes Facebook and
Twitter all with a single click you can
find candidates in any city or industry
nationwide you post once and you watch
the candidates roll on into zip
recruiters easy to use interface and you
can quickly screen candidates and you
can rake them and you can hire the right
person fast using that zip recruiter
interface it's been used by Fortune 100
companies all over the world and
thousands of small and medium-sized
businesses as well we will definitely be
using it over here at the Daily wire
right now my listeners can post jobs on
zip recruiter for free for free by going
to zip recruiter comm slash daily wire
so you get the whole shebang for free
you can post those jobs for free at zip
recruiter com daily wire used slash
daily wire because that enables you to
to let them know that we sent you and
also you get that that free service you
actually get to put up the job for free
and make sure that you can fill that
slot that you desperately need to fill
that's what zip recruiter is for highly
recommend them okay so lots of chaos
last night so it's always irritating
when news breaks really late at night
I'm all ready to go to bed and my kids
have stopped being a pain in the butt
long enough for me to actually relax a
little bit and then Donald from fires
his national security advisor in all
hell breaks I love my children but they
didn't let me sleep a lot last night
neither it turns out did Mike Flynn and
Donald Trump so last night very late
Donald Trump fires Mike Flynn so they're
saying that Mike Flynn resigned and then
Trump accepted the resignation it's the
same
it doesn't really make a difference
bottom line is the national security
adviser he submitted his resignation and
Donald Trump accepted the resignation
which raises a question what exactly did
Michael Flynn do so you may have noticed
that here on the bench Shapiro show we
have not been covering the unfolding
Michael Flynn saga at all at all and
that's a conscious choice and the reason
it's a conscious choice is because there
was no evidence that anything super
wrong happened if they're a bunch of
kind of rumors that maybe Flynn and
talked to the Russians about sanctions
before he was actually national security
adviser well Obama was still president
and then he had denied those rumors and
then the FBI had investigated and they
said they found nothing untoward and so
we didn't cover any of that because it
just seemed like a lot of back-and-forth
and frankly even if it had come out that
National Security Advisor General
Michael Flynn had spoken with the
Russian ambassador about sanctions I
don't think it's that big a deal I don't
I mean who's gonna be the National
Security Advisor in like three weeks
Trump was gonna be President in three
weeks Barack Obama was openly offering
flexibility to the Russians in the
middle of an election campaign as
president of the United States in 2008
Barack Obama reached out to the Iranian
government before he was president to
tell them to just hold on he was coming
to help so I didn't see that any of this
as a big deal like I don't I still don't
understand what the huge deal here was
here's sort of the timeline okay
in a February 8th interview this
recording of a Washington Post in a
February 8th interview with The
Washington Post Flynn categorically
denied discussing sanctions with Russian
ambassador Sergei krisily ACK repeating
public assertions made in January by top
trump officials so vice-president pence
had said that that that Flynn never
talked to kiss lyac about about
sanctions and so did Sean Spicer one day
after the interview Flynn revised his
account he told The Washington Post
through a spokesman he couldn't be
certain the topic never came up US
intelligence reports during the 2016
campaign showed Chris lyac was in touch
with Flynn according to officials
communications between the two continued
after Trump's victory on November 8th
according to officials with access to
intelligence reports on this matter so
Trump officials including as I say
Spicer and vice-president pence they had
said the same thing to the media that
that Flynn had said which is that he
never talked sanctions now then it what
this has been a big deal even if he did
talk sanctions again I don't really see
why it would I don't see why it would
nonetheless he has now resigned
supposedly he resigned the reason that
they're giving for him resigning is
because they say that he lied to pence
that he told pence he didn't discuss
sanctions he actually discussed
sanctions Flint and then pence went on
national TV and then he was undercut by
the fact that Flint had actually talked
sanctions and so he had to go maybe
maybe I find it highly doubtful that
that couldn't be fixed with an apology
that Donald Trump couldn't just gone to
Flint and say you need to apologize to
pence I understand that you didn't think
pens need to be on the loop on that but
he needs to be in the loop on that you
need to issue a public apology and we
all move on with our lives
the idea that that was enough to fire
him that doesn't seem particularly
plausible flares Flynn's resignation
letter so here's what he said he said in
the course of my duties as the incoming
National Security Advisor I held
numerous phone calls with foreign
counterparts ministers and ambassadors
these calls were to facilitate a smooth
transition and begin to build the
necessary relationship between the
president his advisers and foreign
leaders such calls are standard practice
in any transition of this magnitude okay
that seems like a pretty good excuse for
everything that right there
he says unfortunately because of the
fast pace of events I inadvertently
briefed the vice president-elect and
others with incomplete information
regarding my phone calls with the
Russian ambassador I've sincerely
apologized to the president and the VP
and they've accepted my apology you
would think that would be the end of it
right but no he actually resigned and
then he goes on to talk about how he's
tendering his resignation and he's
honored to serve president Trump and he
wants to thank Trump for his personal
loyalty and the friendship of people he
worked with throughout the hard-fought
campaign and he talks about president
Trump's leadership etc etc etc so
they're a bunch of theories floating
around about what actually happened here
because here's the deal okay they're a
bunch of leaks that came out of the
administration suggesting that Flynn had
actually talked sanctions on the line
but it was Trump that had to fire him
Trump had to accept the resignation okay
so this is on Trump the real question
here is why Trump why he accepted the
resignation we understand why the Intel
community is targeting Trump a lot of
the Intel community was appointed under
Obama we understand they're members of
the Intel community who are upset with
the idea that Trump might be close to
the Russians okay those are leaks
they're not good and Trump has responded
to that we'll get to the leaking in just
a second but the real question here is
why Trump accepted
resignation in the first place and there
are a few theories floating around so
I'm just gonna offer you the theories
and you decide for yourself based on
evidence as it comes in theory one is he
lied appends he and presumably Trump
didn't know about it either right and so
Flynn basically went rogue and lied to
everybody about having discussed
sanctions on this call so I think that's
a super plausible theory not only it's a
super plausible theory that he was
discussing sanctions on this phone call
with the Russians and he lied to
everybody and that pissed off Trump so
much the Trump had to let him go that
that does not seem super plausible to me
specifically because Trump knew one
month ago that this was the case and
then he proceeded to appoint Flynn
anyway so that seems implausible there's
another theory and I think this is the
most plausible theory which is that
Trump said to Flynn you go ahead and you
talk to the Russian ambassador say what
you want to say he didn't explicitly
tell him to talk about sanctions but
Flynn talked about sanctions and then
there was blowback and Trump didn't like
the blowback and so he threw Flynn under
the bus so Flynn offered his resignation
and there was all these leaks coming out
suggesting strong ties between Flynn and
the Russians despite the fact that
people have been accusing Flynn of this
for literally months and trump and going
along with him and so Trump said okay
you have to go and he used the the Pens
thing as sort of a pretext
then there's Theory three which is that
Pence and Reince Priebus the the RNC
chair
they have enough sway within the
administration to force Trump to toss
Flynn out on his ear for lying to them
again I find that implausible Trump's
the President of the United States
if pence doesn't like it pens can stick
it I mean Trump's alone with the power
and then finally there's the fourth
theory and that's the one the left is
glomming on to and that's the theory
that the real reason that Trump
decapitated Flynn is because he thought
that this was gonna lead back to him
that he actually told Flynn go make nice
with the Russians he was afraid that
that was going to come out and then it
did start to come out so he decapitated
Flynn hoping that end the story right
that's that sort of the the theory and
the left is relying upon one thing is
clear there is absolute chaos inside the
administration so yesterday we played a
clip of Stephen Miller the adviser to to
senior adviser to to President Trump
talking about how to say that we are in
control of events is significant
understatement
that's not what it looked like today and
again if you're rooting for Trump to do
well then you need him to do better than
this if you're rooting for Trump to have
a successful presidency you need him to
do better than this and don't worry
we'll talk about the Democratic
hypocrisy because there's tons of it
we'll talk about the media
wanting to get Trump because it really
is vicious and nasty and drooling but
first we have to talk about what's
actually going on so yes there is chaos
inside the administration that chaos was
it was on full display yesterday
Kellyanne Conway goes on national TV
this is like three 20 in the afternoon
Pacific time she goes on national TV and
she says the general Flint has Trump's
full thrust
yes general Flynn does enjoy the full
confidence of the President and he's a
big week for general Flynn he's the
point of contact for many of these
foreign visits if you look at the
official schedule today we had the Prime
Minister of Canada Justin Trudeau here
obviously for bilateral meetings on
Wednesday we're welcoming Benjamin
Netanyahu here to the White House and
behind the scenes they're doing a number
of different meetings where they're
talking about trade they're talking
about terrorism security the fact that
Canada n-- the u.s. are writing about of
mine is she says that Flynn has Trump's
full trust and then literally within an
hour so I guess that's about four
o'clock Eastern Time so literally within
an hour Sean Spicer comes out and issues
a statement saying we're going to be
releasing a statement about this so
clearly one hand is not talking to the
other in any of this and remember Donald
Trump said just like last Friday that he
had no idea was going on with Fellaini
hadn't been reading any of the reports
he said he didn't know what reports that
people were even talking about this clip
I don't know about it I haven't seen
what reporters
okay he hasn't seen it he'll look into
it except that the report said that he
was briefed on it over a month ago okay
so there's a lot of confusion happening
and then finally Flynn is gone and Paul
Ryan comes out and says that Trump made
the right decision on the Flynn
resignation well security is perhaps the
most important function or
responsibility a president has and I
think the president made the right
decision to ask for his resignation you
cannot have a national security adviser
misleading the vice president and others
so I think the president was right to
ask for his resignation okay so even
there there's a communications gap
because Trump says that Flynn offered
his resignation and now Ryan is saying
the Trump asks for his resignation right
so there's all sorts of communications
gaps here and a lot of confusion as to
what exactly is going on one thing is
clear we're not we don't know all the
facts yet so all we can do is wait to
hear all the facts again I'm puzzled the
reason I'm you know talking about this
and the reason I think it's interesting
is because I'm puzzled as to why any of
this was fireable I just don't see like
of all the things that people around
Ahnold Trump have done throughout the
campaign and afterward that are that
merit firing it seems to me the talking
to the Russians about sanctions before
you actually take office is like the
last thing on the list that's really low
on the list and fibbing to Mike Pence
and Sean Spicer you think that Trump
cares deeply about that and maybe he
does if so that be the first time that
he's really doing that tight with with
either of those guys and Paul Ryan
obviously as part of the sort of Reince
Priebus wigman wants to see flynn go so
there's a lot of talk today about the
conflict inside the administration
between Steve Bannon and his wing of the
administration and the and the Reince
Priebus wing of the administration
because bannon's outlets like Breitbart
today they're pushing Priebus like the
headline at Breitbart today was that
basically Priebus is responsible for
flinty ouster even though Trump is the
one who did the firing so a lot of
confusion raining so the best available
explanation the easiest available
explanation and the minimum explanation
is that there's a lot of amateurish Ness
and incompetence happening at the
highest levels with regard to with
regard to this particular issue and
that's not a good thing now there's
another issue that may be even deeper
there's another issue here that may be
even deeper and that is the leaks so
again we don't because we don't know the
extent of what
actly happened here wide from fired
Flynn again that's the big question why
did he accept the resignation there is a
secondary question and this is what
Trump is focusing in on Trump tweeted
out today that what the real issue here
is the leaks why is his administration
so damn leaky he tweeted out the real
story here is why are there so many
illegal leaks coming out of Washington
will these leaks be happening as I deal
on North Korea etc Trump is obviously
very frustrated with the intelligence
community he's been saying they've been
leaking about him for literally months
and he's not wrong they have been
there's a certain irony to Donald Trump
being very angry at leaks considering
that for literally a year and a half he
was happy with leaks so long as they
helped him now he's unhappy with leaks
if they don't help him but it does
demonstrate that the Intel community the
the so-called deep state is very
invested in hurting Donald Trump and
taking out a lot of people around him is
that for good reasons is that for bad
reasons we don't know but it's not a
good thing okay the Intel community is
not supposed to be waging war against
the administration that it's that it's
supposed to be serving
and so Trump has a point here he does
have a point now it still doesn't answer
the question right the the Intel
community could be leaking and Trump
could have just said so what leak what
you want
I'm keeping Flynn deal but he didn't and
that keeps that first question what is
from doing on the table but yes the
Intel community and their focus on Trump
is gonna be a long-standing problem for
Trump I'm not sure how he cleans house
I'm not sure what he does about it so
two things can be true once the leaks
can be really egregious and they can be
really heavy and second there could be
something nefarious going on inside the
Trump administration and we have to have
an explanation as to why Trump actually
fired Flynn if nothing bad was happening
here again I'm looking at the scandal
and I don't see the scandal like where's
the scandal why is it a scandal that the
the future NSA talks to the Russians I
don't get it that Trump's thought was
enough of a scandal to fire somebody so
we're not getting the full story in all
of that and that's and that's a problem
it's still raising you know credibility
issues Matt Lauer interviewed Kellyanne
Conway about this and you can see the
confusion you can see the fact that we
now have a scandal on our hands because
of what appears to be sort of a cover-up
from the Trump administration
here's Matt Lauer with Kellyanne Conway
and Kellyanne looks really bad in this
exchange well that's that's one
characterization but the
fact is that general flame continued in
that position and was in the
presidential daily briefings was part of
the leader calls as recently as
yesterday was there for the Prime
Minister's visit from Canada yesterday
and as time wore on obviously the
situation to become unsustainable
General Flint that makes no sense
last month the Justice Department warned
the White House that general Flynn had
misled them and that as a result he was
vulnerable to blackmail and and at that
moment he still had the complete trust
of the president Matt I'm telling you
what the president has said which is
that he's accepted general Flynn's
resignation and he wishes and well and
that we're moving on there's at least
three candidates very strong candidates
that would be considered for a permanent
position here obviously general Keith
Kellogg is the acting national security
adviser starting today and the president
is moving forward and she continues by
saying we're not gonna say what we knew
and when we knew it which is never a
good sign okay you never want an
administration saying that we're gonna
get to the hypocrisy of the Democrats in
the media here in just a second because
it is rich it is rich there's there's
absolutely rich disgusting hypocrisy
from the Democrats and the media the
media are claiming this is the biggest
cover-up the biggest story since
iran-contra absolute garbage not true
the Obama administration was replete
with corrupt nasty officials doing
corrupt nasty things were never fired by
Obama at least Trump fired Flynn okay so
we still have to know why I think that's
the big question here because again I
don't see what Flynn did that was so
wrong here that an apology couldn't have
solved but the idea that this is
unprecedented that this is something new
that this is the worse since iran-contra
bunch of crap just absolute crap the
National Security Adviser under Barack
Obama Ben Rhodes was literally a fiction
writer who literally wrote a fictional
story about how Iran had reached out to
the United States the moderates and Ron
over an Iran nuclear deal the entire
media swallowed the entire thing whole
and then and then Rhodes came out and
said he I fooled you all and no one
cared okay Susan Rice the UN Ambassador
went on national television and lied it
was at 13 times about how a YouTube
video was responsible for what happened
in Benghazi or she was lied to by the
CIA it's the same sort of situation and
no one seemed to care on the left so
there's rich hypocrisy happening all
over from the Democrats the media but
we'll get to
just a second to see that you're gonna
have to subscribe to daily wire.com head
to daily wired.com right now for the
rest of the show eight dollars a month
will buy a subscription and if you buy
the annual subscription right now you
get a free copy of the arroyo which is a
terrific fictional film made by our very
own jeremy boring about the southern
border and the and the the war that's
happening on the southern border it
really in some ways priests aged a lot
of the immigration debate that's been
happening in the country for the last
two years very good film the arroyo you
can get that for free when you subscribe
annually at daily wire.com plus a
shapiro store is coming in all sorts of
future goodies are coming to daily
wire.com so check that out we are the
largest conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
you